welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange and multiverse
of madness just released some new
footage in a cinemark trailer i mean
between this and a spokeswoman who's
definitely been to an amc before nicole
kidman i am obviously obsessed with the
film exhibitors joining the marketing
phrase so let's take a look here if
you're watching doctor strange on a
screen this small oh i would never
you're in the wrong universe oh
experience the multiverse of madness
the weight was truly meant to be seen
okay
i mean was anyone planning on watching
multiverse of menace on an iphone 4 from
the end of a long hallway now that i'm
complaining because there were
definitely a couple new shots in there
that we should break down especially
since they do connect to some new clues
for the scarlet witch that we have not
really talked about yet now first was
this shot of doctor strange saying prove
it you can see on the right side of the
frame that he is talking to america
chavez and this might be part of the
scene where she flees down the street
from gargantos with doctor strange
slicing that bus in half while other
sorcerers slayed the creature i'm
curious to know what doctor strange was
asking her to prove perhaps that she's
from another reality one in which she
had a friendship with doctor strange she
knows everything about him so he's like
prove it and she's like i know you use a
guard from a box to form that goatee and
he's like no man but we should also
remember that doctor strange now exists
in reality where the runes of cough call
have left him memory wiped from the
history that involved peter parker from
his perspective spider-man does exist
but he never knew that hero without his
mask on and so all the memories he had
of spider-man were memories of a
spider-man who stayed masked the entire
time an infinity war and an end game and
never revealed his name strange also
indicated to wong that he had used this
spell several times before
we've used it for a lot less do you
remember the full moon party at comtaj
no exactly as we saw with peter having
to take the ged to regain his academic
records that spell warps reality to
justify people being faded from memories
so the fact that strange could just
consider it a standard memory spell and
then have used it more than once in the
past leads us to wonder what other
components of the mcu reality have we
all taken for granted that might have
actually have been the result of past
gaslighting on all of us the prove it
that strange charges that american
chavez might actually be in response to
her telling them that the mcu reality of
earth 19999
is a flawed incomplete reality really
the redheaded step reality like how the
hell do you not have mutants in a
fantastic four in your universe why is
everyone so confused how the defenders
and the ages of shield fit in it's
because this universe is already patched
with duct tape after infinite glitches
in the matrix that we never were aware
of and the only sensible way forward is
to reboot it i mean it's either that
folks or prove it is strange's response
to america telling him that gargantos is
his bastard's son prove it oh wait i did
hook up with nyarlathotep at that full
moon party now another new shot that
looked pretty sick was of the scarlet
witch's seance with the camera orbiting
her as she levitates camera now takes on
the point of view of one of those red
chaos magic orbs that revolved around
her the last time we saw her in this
pose in the one division post-credits
scene now we know this seance is going
to be an important part of the film it
has appeared in every trailer for the
film and was depicted on the cover
artwork of empire magazine i have
speculated that this could be taking
place in the courtyard of camaratosh
based on the floor tile beneath her feet
matching the geometric tile
configuration we've seen elsewhere in
camara taj like in the shot of wintra
and the other sorcerers being attacked
with explosions but this orbital shot
shows us more the surrounding
architecture in the background including
the inner chamber directly behind wanda
lit with a golden glow and at the far
end three windows that open up to a pale
blue and white location i wondered if
these could be a type of rotunda gateway
for camartage like the one wong and
strange left open to siberia that
allowed a blizzard to freeze the
interior of the new york sanctum one of
the rotunda gateways connects to siberia
but blizzard blasted through
because someone forgot to cast a monthly
maintenance spell to keep the seals
tight by the way i still find it
interesting why spider-man no way home
would go to so much effort to construct
an entire frozen sanctum set just for a
throwaway joke and it reminds me a lot
of how sony allowed skrulls to tie into
spider-man far from home as a concession
to their producing partners marvel
studios for a separate project that
feige had in the works and that the
frozen sanctum with the rotunda gateway
left open could actually be a plot point
that will come back in multiverse
madness i might be overthinking it i do
that a lot but that set and its multiple
phases of dethaling throughout the film
just would have been a sizable chunk of
the production budget for just one gag
with zero other plot implications now
sure marvel pours cash into resizing
gags in the ant-man movies but those set
pieces are really core to the appeal of
the ant-man world the reason people go
watch those movies but a frozen sanctum
had nothing to do with the spider-man
movie this is just a mouthful of saying
that doctor strange and wong's unclosed
rotunda gateway could be a symptom of
bigger problems within the sorcerer
network at the very least sorcerer's
supreme wong letting its
responsibilities fall through the cracks
because other crises are demanding his
attention which would explain why he was
rushing back to camertaj in no way home
i've also been pointing out how the
transportation methods for characters
multiverse and madness based on other
trailer footage seems to be broken or at
least disabled at the moment no one in
the footage we've seen so far has used
sling ring portals once instead we've
been seeing other magical ways of
getting around like trick doors star
portals maybe after ned overused sling
ring portals and no way home the
sorcerers have for now shut down the
whole network the windows behind wanda
in her seance could be that new york
sanctum's glitchy rotunda gateway link
frozen on the other side that wanda
could have used to transport herself to
camartage or alternatively this gateway
could be an exit point to another
location like the blue tinted british
museum set of the illuminati citadel
which we know wanda will also attack in
another sequence of the film but my
favorite new detail about wanda is in
her new scarlet witch costume which ever
since we realized this is an upgrade
from the wandavision version of the look
we keep finding more details hidden in
the design here like the mind stone
shaped opening on the collar to show her
ongoing grief over losing vision but the
empire magazine photos gave us a clearer
look at the text strain throughout these
wardrobe pieces her tiara her shoulders
her chest pieces are all covered in
these scratches and if you look closely
they're all radiating outward from her
heart just a fascinating way of showing
how all of wanda's actions in this film
her breaking of reality or breaking into
the multiverse all stem from a broken
heart you can follow me on instagram and
twitter ida boss follow me rockstar
subscribe to rockstar some more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you